[music playing]
NARRATOR: Is this coffee?
Why, no.
This is coffee.
[music playing]
NARRATOR: The taste
of fine coffee
extend over a wide range.
But for each palate, there is
a flavor that is just right.
Around the world, they
drink this beverage
in it's many exotic forms.
How then do we make a perfect
cup of coffee to our taste?
Success lies in a single word--
care.
Three simple ingredients go
into the brewing process--
water, fresh and
carefully measured,
coffee, the proper grind,
and carefully measured, time,
carefully measured.
A simple recipe
for perfect coffee.
Perfect coffee.
It helps to start the day
with warmth and vigor.
[music playing]
NARRATOR: It is a pleasant
splurge of the mornings work.
It provides the essential
part of our pause at noon,
indispensable during that
unhurried hour in a world
that often forgets to stop.
In the romance of evening
when young dreams glow softly,
coffee is always a
perfect companion.
And after dinner, it is
at home in any setting
when good taste is important.
In the end, it remains a
simple thing, easy to attain,
well made and well enjoyed.
A good cup of good coffee.